So this guy Ed Klein has written a book
called 'Blood Feud' and it's all about how
the Obama's hate the clinton's and the
clintons hate the Obama's
like Romeo and Juliet and he summed up
his book
in a New York Post peace yesterday let's
take a look at what he said
so Obama has authorize his chief
political adviser Valerie Jarrett to
convince
Elizabeth Warren to write she is the
progressive obviously Massachusetts will
talk about
her more in a second Jarrett other
theories a secret meetings with
more where she explained that Obama is
worried that hillary succeed him in the
white house she may I do
many of his policies basically implying
that hillary isn't as all at
as Obama is that she's more centrist and
Obama not happy about that
and Obama believes that war is the best
person to convince the party that
hillary's out of touch with poor
American
and the middle class Warren in his new
would carry on the Obama legacy
after he leaves the White House they get
into a lot of personal stuff about why
they hate each other that clinton is
talk about how much he hates Obama and
all backed up
we talk in the last couple weeks a lot
about how he repeats pretending she poor
she says she went into the white house
broken she came out dad now
just really just not true she's never
not had a video that you want at any and
thresher
a but I think this is kinda interesting
that Obama
he was your secretary of state everyone
thinks that you know he brought her in
doing the fledgling again with it just
Rs she was his secretaries day
a whoever 111 where the eye but that
everyone thinks that they sorta made by
anybody and he did like Abraham Lincoln
thing in with you know where you
bring in people that you don't
necessarily agree with that kinda
just coalesce around you team Doris
Kearns Goodwin's
yet that bad getting a book in the area
the whole XO
I i think is kinda interesting that if
any of this is true when I don't know
that it is but this guy seems to there
is research
that he really wants someone else
besides her to run someone who was in
his administration
woody maker I mean I think that this
article is a lot of fear-mongering so is
the book trying to be divisive in this
moment and try to make hillary seem out
of touch and everything else I gotta
mean the Republican should be
afraid of Hillary running I i'm clearly
they are
I am you know I I like Elizabeth Warren
a lot done so for me that thought of her
running for president is very exciting
we had a Clinton in a bush in the White
House for a very very long time
answer to get a little bit a fresh
perspective is exciting to me but I
think that this book is sort of a lot
about fierer
not that we're putting out yet so I
agree and I don't want to focus on the
book it just sort it out because yeah
this guy
we don't know a lot of this is true but
the general idea Nov
that Elizabeth Warren would be much
better if we really want change in this
country
and we were and the banks I mean
hillary's taken a ton from Goldman Sachs
you can order doesn't produce pages
but shouldn't we all want the
anti-collision or you know
the politics you don't effin
you always get them the person you want
the best person in office because I'm
you really have to be concerned with was
electable right and
mom seething she'd be like off the deep
end for most sorta middle well I think
she would be harder
to be put in office I think the anime
certainly no political sage
hi I think that she would be hard to put
into office
then clinton at this point clinton has
so much momentum
yeah and on just there would be a lot
dead I think one would have to do yet to
get up to that point
om but I like her yeah I really like her
a lot
the the Hillary risks her moment it was
a little too early I mean this election
is still it was two years away
you know yeah but isn't as important as
an important time right now i i think
that you're absolutely right like a
warren would have a very hard time
getting elected in clinton's the showing
up for me
Obama has to also see all that we're
talking about is like mister harris also
if
really true with the skies what I like
you know he's wrapping up post me I'm I
the evening New York Post and I just
don't you know I
and definitely not fair that unfair me I
do like how I in the first three stories
me that I linked you to break par that
comment you are posting I mean like a
lot of driving good evening or Thursday
I'm trying to get sources that maybe we
don't agree with a little bit yeah I
know but I think it's an interesting I
think it's interesting to think about
war and in this case and also I think
about hillary and and and
and in this moment it's it's important
that that we i
I think that my party at least rallies
around somebody who we think can really
bring about the the most change for this
kind that only means a change again by
have nowhere to try to call again
they're like this critical junction with
the environment and went to immigration
now
and and certainly with the supreme court
and her Supreme Court is gonna hang in
the balance with whoever's on Amex and
this is like a critical moment yeah
but also you know you know I think all
of us
are are naive when it comes to politics
mom
because heart knows what wouldn't want
more million who's behind term with beer
manufacturing for her and that means
politics yeah
gotta be something I like that about
everything but its use shorter gotta
just pick some stuff to believe that run
it that otherwise
you know who the hell knows what's in
Charlie how do I have no idea
no I mean do you think women the would
turn against Elizabeth Warren if she ran
against Hillary
because obviously women usually are
supporting Hillary and I think it's just
cuz she's a woman
but the idea that another woman with and
try to run against her which then they'd
say you're gonna split the female
alaska right after that with the female
vote and there'd be no I'm not because
I'm so stupid
writing that's like but you know they
say it you know they had a real you know
they're they're
they love to do that they let me love to
paint women as as catch fighters
now and and that and that's insulting
writer Mendon turn against ross perot
wrapper around the hell is he a women
are you novel 10
still rather novelty it like that as a
comic
yeah you know when you when you're on a
show again anti-women Shiraz had a minor
she said everything I've yeah
but you know I'm just I'm its its it's
an unfair
it's an unfair highlight I just aid it
bothers me and i'd
and and nothing it back to be done but
it's wrong yeah arts a final thought on
this
a should we care what and how going
president thinks or who he endorses like
even if you love Obama
whoever the president is that at that
point you had your eye on you had your
eight years you did everything you could
do
for good or bad and then at that point
we don't shouldn't matter who you
endorse that sorta what I think but not
a majority is not be ambushed
school event right disappear into her
yeah you know a preferential right
engine clear brush yeah I don't know for
me I think it's a i
it's vital it's important but you know
what president clinton comes and and
stands behind its a horn I think wound
eww indoors and it's important for me to
Karl Rove indoors is important for me
the apple of his got home runs by the
bat is gonna pay what I think is better
right
like anything in life I mean you want to
go to a docking at her for all
running you know you want you want to
know what other people
ben Crane who knew in my only respect
only don't respect yeah I know whether
or not the political climate shows that
an endorsement from Obama's actually
gonna be a negative and they all got the
other
grab modern be negative some money right
you know mean very well